bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cet autre cas dit ce matin notre
invité daniel robin bonjour bonjour
bertrand bonjour martiniquaise de
martiniquais daniel robin conseiller
territorial donc à l'assemblée de
martinique alors l'actualité toute
récente
c'est le budget primitif 2021 justement
de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique un budget primitif pour cette
année qui s'élève à un milliard deux
cent cinquante trois millions alors la
majorité ou en tout cas une bonne partie
de la majorité
affiché à l'air fier d'afficher une
hausse de 165 millions avec ce budget
2021 et notamment la partie
investissement double plus 50% pour se
monter à 3 180 2 millions d'euros et
donc la majorité disent que c'est un
budget qui s'adapte à la situation de la
crise sanitaire est aussi social et
économique mais c'est pas votre lecture
vous daniel rubin et non parce qu'en
fait d'abord le budget de l'année
dernière dans son exécution traduit quoi
c'est que l'emprunt qui avaient été
positionnés de façon là aussi offensif
puisqu'il s'agissait de 230 millions
d'euros n'a pas été intégralement
mobilisés à dire qu au plus fort de la
crise la l'exécutif de la ctm a estimé
que la martinique n'avait pas besoin que
tous les moyens soient mis en oeuvre
pour réduire les réalités difficiles et
ô combien que nos compatriotes
connaissent dans leur vie qu'il s'agisse
des personnes qu'il s'agit des
associations qu'ils s'agissent des
entreprises 105 millions disponibles
n'ont mobilisé cette année qu'est ce
qu'on nous dit on va faire un emprunt
complémentaire de 170 millions qui vient
couvrir cette augmentation budgétaire de
165 millions que vous avez justement
analysé identifier nous nous pensons que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour la ctn ce n'est
plus l'affichage surtout à quelques mois
des élections il s'agit d'être
responsable et de faire en sorte que
tout ce qui doit être fait le soin sans
attendre sans différé parce que la
martinique va très mal
alors pour vous là avec cette
présentation d'une augmentation
265 millions dont la partie
investissement double par rapport à 2020
à l'exercice 2020 pour vous il y a là
une opération électoraliste en tout cas
vous dit que c'est une présentation je
crois que vous avez d'ailleurs utilisé
le terme en trompe l'oeil tout à fait
leurs gammes que j'ai employé pendant
ces dernières il ya deux trois jours
c'est très simple d'abord on peut pas
s'extasier du fait que le budget
d'investissement de l'année dernière
était de l'ordre de 130 millions se
passe c'est que ça c'est bien la région
sol faisait déjà cela donc voyez ce
n'est pas extra mais lorsque nous avons
analysé les taux d'exécution de céder
aux délires la réalité de ce qui a été
mise en oeuvre
on se rend compte que les taux
d'exécution de la section
d'investissement sont les moins élevés
donc on peut empiler et affiché encore
une fois des enveloppes mais si elles ne
sont pas mises en oeuvre
cela ne sert à rien est sûr c'est que
nous disons attention danger
on ne peut pas considérer que nous
sommes dans une période qui justifie
justement qu'il y ait encore des
manoeuvres électorales alors alfred
marie-jeanne le président du conseil
exécutif qui est déjà candidat à sa
propre succession qui est déjà en
campagne
lui continue à jouer beaucoup sur le
thème de bain regardez je suis un bon
gestionnaire et puis je finalement
j'affronte la situation voilà je je je
suis l'homme avec mon équipe
wild one pour ce type de situation de
crise là mais de quel alfred
marie-jeanne parlons nous est-ce qu'il
s'agisse de celui qui était voilà dans
une vertu dans une rigueur budgétaire ou
celui qui affiche aujourd'hui un
endettement de 900 millions d'euros pour
laquelle la collectivité presque 900
millions d'euros ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quasiment plus de
marge de manoeuvre à la collectivité
est ce qu'il s'agit de celui qui était
encore une fois vanté jamais vraiment
cru à sa comme étant un bon gestionnaire
savez dans une collectivité
l'enjeu c'est quoi d'abord d'identifier
les besoins de couvrir des besoins et de
mobiliser des moyens pour y arriver
lorsque j'entends l'exécutif puisque
c'était le cas mais vraiment nous dire
que nous allons réellement mobiliser les
fonds européens est une plaisanterie fin
là justement vous avez aussi eu à redire
sur
sur la consommation des fonds européens
la consommation des fonds européens
d'abord c'est pas une découverte qui a
la possibilité d'accéder à des fonds
d'état à des fonds européens et pourquoi
pas à défaut internationaux enfin il
faut être clair donc lors c'est une
consommation trop timide fois ci
l'opposition dit qu'elle n'a pas dépassé
les 35 % alors d'abord nous n'avons
avoir du mal à avoir des chiffres une
fois de plus donc ce qui est important
encore une fois c'est de ne pas
découvrir subitement à quelques mois
d'une élection qu'il y aurait des
possibilités de mobiliser des fonds ils
doivent l'être
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre du premier
jour de l'élection jusqu'au dernier jour
du mandat
et si on est dans une réalité on les
découvre c'est qu'on n'est pas un bon
gestionnaire de alors le budget
finalement a été adoptée à 11 voix
contre 8 abstentions
vous même vous êtes vous avez voté
contre deux vigiles étaient carrément
oui donc vraiment merci mes analyses
sont relativement simples
encore une fois une collectivité en
période de crise ne doit pas être dans
une démarche d'affichage elle doit être
efficace
alors on va en venir à la campagne
électorale alors à l'heure où on parle
là ce matin les dates restent encore les
13 et 20 juin
mais mais mais il y en a qui disent même
qu'il est de plus en plus probable que
finalement ces dates seront repoussées
alors le conseil scientifique à paris a
remis hier au premier ministre un avis
sur la tenue ou non finalement des
élections régionales ou territoriale
pour nous à ces dates et le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'il suivrait
strictement
la vie préconisé par le conseil
scientifique vous même compte tenu des
dernières tendances
ici ou là bas quel est votre sentiment
c'est ce qui est extrêmement difficile
c'est d'avoir une position claire
puisque vous même vous le dit conseil
scientifique et rapport il y aura des
annonces dans la semaine c'est comme ce
que j'ai appris tout à l'heure
concernant l'évolution du confinement en
martinique
face à cela il ya une seule stratégie
qui vaille c'est poursuivre notre
démarche de façon à ce qu'il y ait à
travers des réseaux numériques la
campagne digitale des éléments qui nous
permettent d'entretenir ce lien avec nos
remerciements et fès et les martillacais
mais on est dans une incertitude et
surtout messi devait daniel robin s'il
devait y avoir joué aux jouets c'est que
les éléments prix qui préexistait en
fait au mois de novembre lors du dernier
report sont plus grave aujourd'hui qu'il
ne l'était à l'époque
justement est ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il
faut repousser de quelques mois parce
que ça non mais attendez il ya la
situation effectivement je dirais
sanitaire elle même
et puis il ya les considérations
évidemment on parle de politique là de
calendrier politique il ya des
considérations à les politiciennes on va
dire comme ça ou en tout cas de ce qu'il
faut repousser en octobre ou est-ce
qu'il faut carrément a fixé sa après
l'élection présidentielle oui je suis
candidat à une élection
je me conforme aux règles que le
gouvernement édicte pour pouvoir y
participer
je n'ai aucune capacité d'influer sur ce
que le gouvernement va décider
maintenant il est important que les
décisions soient prises et qu'elles ne
soient rapidement parce que mort je sais
quoi c'est la participation c'est la
mobilisation des citoyennes et des
ajustements de ce point de vue belle
le citoyen français a fortiori
martiniquais que vous êtes parce qu'on
voit bien que cette campagne
elle est finalement tributaire aussi
d'une autre campagne c'est celle de la
vaccination
parce que si la vaccination se passe
bien eh bien peut-être peut-être que on
peut se dire oui à la fin de l'année ça
aura lieu écoutez il y a un enjeu alors
je pars de la martinique
j'étais en contact et oui mais je pense
ici à lyon qui avait à peine il ya à
peine 15 min martiniquais qui ont été
vaccinées voyez donc on est très loin de
la possibilité qu'il y ait de considérer
qu' on est soit dans une immunité
collective ou que la réalité du nombre
de vaccinations permet de lever des
mesures nous sommes sous couvre feu nous
le rappelons quand même et que le préfet
nous nous nous menace peut être là aussi
de confinement donc soyons certains que
l'enjeu est effectivement c'est
d'organiser des élections dans les
meilleures conditions pour que les
citoyennes et me soit 6,1 soit rassurez
vous vous êtes pressés vous est pris je
suis serein vous êtes déjà en campagne
vous êtes serein
est-ce que vous l'exemple que si vous
êtes vraiment le sérieux dans trois mois
de juin nous sommes prêts nous serons
encore davantage si c'est l'année
prochaine après les élections
présidentielles d'avril risquerez
l'egypte savez il est je pense qu' il ne
faut pas mélanger ce type d'élection une
élection territoriale pour nous mérite
d'être considéré comme un scrutin à part
entière laissons les législatives et les
présidentielles qui sont des scrutins
nationaux à leur place et travaillons
ensemble donc on veut qu'elle se passe
dans de bonnes conditions
voilà on a compris que vous seriez
plutôt favorable à ce que ce soit des
couples et un dd des législatives ont
fait après éventuellement la
présidentielle et donc que ça
intervienne soit la fin de l'année ou
peut-être en début d'année prochaine
on verra alors les conditions de cette
campagne particulière pour votre groupe
que on le rappelle qui est donc baptisé
chemin d'avenir mais chemin ou au
singulière ah oui ils soient pas des
chômeurs c'est parce que ça venir une
seule voie nous ne sommes pas en train
de perdre le peuple martiniquais qui lui
même a besoin de clarté et donc nous
avons effectivement tracer un chemin
d'avenir parce que nous pensons que la
martinique a besoin d'une espérance
ouais alors pourquoi faire campagne en
dehors de l'alliance avec laquelle vous
avez été élu
il y a un peu plus de cinq ans c'était
avec ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle bon qui a changé de nom
maintenant l'alliance c'est un nouveau
groupe est alors allez-y pourquoi
d'abord être sorti de ce groupe là dans
cette famille là je ne suis plus membre
du parti politique
goyer tête dans l'alliance donc qui est
toujours dans l'alliance qui savaient le
parti bruce hills martinique et je n'en
suis plus donc a fortiori mon
appartement à la non appartenance à ce
que j'ai du mal à qualifier ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle l'alliance
ce rappel concerne part du virtuel est
une alliance donc aujourd'hui non il me
semble que les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour que nous puissions nous
retrouver pleinement dans ce cas avait
il ne s'agit pas de changer l'étiquette
d'un produit pour en changer
fondamentalement la nature sauf
contretemps serge letchimy a annoncé
être candidat à la candidature
voilà donc vous allez vous retrouver
peut-être pas opposé mais pas loin en
tout cas face à face vous savez question
de la démocratie elle et elle est simple
on où elle se résout en permettant à des
offres politiques différentes d'être
mise voilà en propositions aux
martiniquais aux martiniquais et je
pense qu'il faut respecter cela
c'est un temps extrêmement importante
pour le pays et nous avons à coeur de
porter une offre politique différente de
façon à ce que nous soyons en capacité
de solliciter les suffrages alors pour
conclure on à voir sur quels axes
principal justement vous comptez accès
aux comptes est plutôt orienté votre
votre campagne est votre programme ou en
tout cas l'essentiel des propositions
mais comment dirais je
qu'est ce que vous avez à reprocher
pourquoi avez vous quitté le ppm qu'est
ce que vous avez à me toucher à ce soir
car oui non mais enfin tu fais rire
explique que ça fait trois ans et demi
oui je suis plus membre du parcours gré
6 j'ai été interviewé à de multiples
reprises rush sur ce sujet à un moment
donné j'ai pris une décision qui
consiste aujourd'hui à retrouver de la
citoyenneté dans le cadre de l'action
publique
ça c'est le coeur de notre démarche
c'est ça vous avez lâché un mot là donc
il y avait pas suffisamment de
citoyenneté c'est l'osmose le mode de
fonctionnement du ceta du parti de
gouvernance ça m'a donné un gouvernant
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui rien et
d'ailleurs
se retrouvent dans les réalités de ce
que nous vivons dans l'exécutif de la
ctm qu'il s'agisse de l'un ou de l'autre
donc nous avons à coeur aujourd'hui de
faire en sorte que les martiniquaises et
les martiniquais se réapproprie le débat
public qu'il s'y retrouve qu'ils
puissent y engager de telle sorte qu'il
y ait vraiment à travers ce qu'on nous
dit être une vraie difficulté notre
fierté c'est que des personnes qui
disaient non nous la politique on ne s'y
intéresse pas et bien c'est de pouvoir
leur donner envie d'y prendre leur part
et c'est cela showman année donc c'est
une nouvelle méthode en fait que total
et me reposer absolument à la population
merci daniel robin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci monsieur jugée bonne
semaine nous sommes donc attentifs à ce
qui va se décider concernant les dates
d'un chêne des élections territoriales
voilà 10 me bonne journée
[Musique]